have y'all ever played together have you
ever played with Sheila I didn't realize
that's who I was in the makeup room with
oh my gosh I was like I should have like
You' been like you want to come out and
play with us I I didn't even think of
that but I was like man yall would sound
incredible you're both such amazing
musicians and artists yeah just held her
sticks till she needed them oh my God
she's in she is incredible but I have to
ask you first of all this is amazing the
jacket I'm going to steal it um but you
did you just go to Japan with your son I
did I love Japan I love Japan did you
have such a good time you know I've been
there before probably like you but I've
never gotten to see or look around cuz
we sing and then we do interviews all
day I went for Pure vacation we had the
best time yeah first of all the
strawberry blonde is so your Vibe yeah I
have to compliment it so your son my my
kids um they as they're seven and nine
but they asked to come on stage with me
did your son cuz I know that he he plays
with you sometimes on stage right he's
12 right yeah he played some drums um
and he asked to come out on tour with me
and we had practiced really good and
then he went to his dad's for 2 weeks in
Texas and he got out and we show up to
sound check and y'all he wasn't good you
were just that terrible oh you're like
oh bud did you take some time off you're
like yeah well it was my fault cuz I
didn't rehearse with him prior to
soundcheck and so it was one of those
weird moments as a mom where you're like
oh how do I break the news yeah be
honest yeah cuz you know it's like you'd
rather I mean my mother wasn't me like
it's like you got to be honest with your
kids that way they don't go out there
and like do something they they're like
Mom why didn't you tell me exactly yeah
he a moment though right so he didn't it
didn't work out but then he kind of went
to the bathroom and did you over hear
him talking to himself yeah so I told
him I was like you know first of all I
should have practice with you before
today and you're not quite ready for
tonight but we can practice before
tonight and if you get there we can do
it and if not we have mons on tour yeah
he's like no I want to practice I want
to try and I was like all right so we
start practicing and he misses his
entrance do it again misses his entrance
do it again Miss's entrance and he's
like it's cool it's cool I'll be right
back and he goes into the bathroom and
he shuts the door and I hear him
go here I am crying in the
bathroom and I know I'm not supposed to
be crying cuz it's okay to make
mistakes but it doesn't feel very good
and then it gets quiet for a minute and
then he's like well then he opens the
door and I run back to the bed I'm like
cool cool everything cool what's going
on and he's like let's do it again and
he we kept practicing he practiced for a
long time and he got it to where I was
like if you want you can you can try it
tonight so he walked out there and he
just crushed it it was pretty cool I
love that did you teach him that kind of
emotional maturity because that's pretty
mature for a 12-year-old little kid just
to walk in there and you know walk
yourself through it the best thing I
think for me as a mom has just been
learning to heal and heal my own self
and it's made me a much more available
mom and I know so much more now than I
you know was taught and so yeah teaching
him emotional tools learning how to
label the right feeling cuz a lot of us
like I don't know if y'all I grew up
with emotional dyslexia I was like not
treated very nice and then it was like I
love you it's the wrong word for those
things you know so you kind of match
you're like what does love mean yeah I'm
going to go get in some bad
relationships for a while figure it out
I don't know what you speak of okay so
um so you toured with your parents which
I didn't know that I didn't know both
were musicians so you toured at a very
young age right yeah I started touring
with them I started singing with them at
5 in hotels for tourists wow and then we
would Alaska native Villages Inuit
Villages all through like the Arctic
Circle that's cool yeah so we get
dropped off on a plane on skis and then
a dog sled would pick us up that was our
transpo we this is not normal no we
would stay in a cabin with like a host
family and I remember being given a
barbecued moous leg it was like this
long and I was
like how do you and you're like how do
you approach it how do you how do you
think you go in on that Caveman with a
little bigger than a Dr
that's amazing so your not alone
challenge let's talk about we've talked
about this before but it came back
around this year so it's again happening
what do you want to tell people what if
they haven't heard of not alone
challenge last year was our first time
doing the hashtag not alone challenge
you guys helped me debut it thanks to
you guys we became the the biggest
social media campaign for mental health
I don't think it was us but I think
maybe you had a lot to do I think you
had a huge bit of to do with that um we
reached one and a half billion eyeballs
last year and it really shows I think
like the importance and the need of
social anxiety of different mental
health issues and it's really important
to raise awareness but what we really
want to do with this challenge is make
sure we're putting tools into people's
hands cuz we're about 500,000 therapists
short currently in America and there's
lots of tools that work like CBT and DBT
or learning how to meditate and
different tools yeah there's a lot of
people that live in what I call a mental
health desert where they just don't have
access or money and that's unacceptable
one in four kids right now are having
suicidal ideation that's not a number we
intend to live with no we can really do
something about that absolutely oh my
God so we're doing auction items if
people want to see I mean last year
Billy iish did an incredible package all
sorts of athletes if they go to
not-alone challenge.org they can see
what to I was going to say how else can
people help is that the thing bidding on
things yeah bidding on things really
helps that raises money the foundation
Reserve Social Club is actually going to
match donations up to a million dollars
wow so every dollar y'all give really
really
um and this is again empowering
especially atrisk youth to have mental
health help absolutely which is our
future this year Mar the 25th
anniversary of her multiplatinum album
Spirit which is incredible so this was
your second album right yeah did you
have that sophomore pressure did you
feel it oh my God everybody put that
pressure on you I wouldn't have known
about the sophomore slump and you're
like well thanks for telling me geez I
know people do tell you why I don't know
but it was one of those things I really
had to contend with like my first album
I wrote it not meaning to I just wrote
and my first hit who will save your soul
is the first song I ever wrote I didn't
mean to write it and I didn't need to
write a hit so it was weird to be like
how do I now try to do well it was also
very different like your sound is very
different and it was very different from
anything out yeah so I thought that was
really cool that's why you probably
didn't think oh I don't know if the
masses are gonna boy did we ever yeah
yeah everybody leaned in on that out
yeah that's so nice I know and that was
the thing that really saved me was I had
read I got discovered when I was
homeless and I'd read a book about the
music business called everything you
need to know about the music business I
got it at the library and I read about
contracts and royalties Mechanicals and
advances and so I turned down my advance
I turned down a million dollars as a
homeless kid and I took the biggest back
end anybody had ever been given because
I didn't think a folk record would sell
but if it did sell I would get rewarded
you are the smartest person Al alive and
I had a clause in that for every million
albums I sold I would go up by points I
sold 15 million albums on that first oh
my God
insane so I so basically you didn't have
to work again yeah yeah you didn't have
to work again I never cared about Fame I
never cared about his but you know what
you did you believed in yourself you
believed in your gift and I think that's
more I've turned down money too when
they ask you to do things and I'm like
it's not but then it also tells you it's
like if I'm turning down this much money
does that not tell you something like
that I that you know what I'm saying I
really don't want to do it like if it's
that much money like I'm really not into
that like that should tell you but they
don't care yeah I just really want the
artistic freedom and I wanted to earn it
I didn't want to like have this risk on
the front end yeah um and so that was
the exact attitude I was like wait a
minute I just if I never spend my money
if I'm really careful I never have to
have a hit I don't have to do this I get
to do this really power and then it
still stays your passion and your love
yeah and so I wrote another weird song
like where the entire Bridge was like in
the end only kindness matters the
label's like that's the whole bridge I'm
like yep that's the that's the whole
Bridge like it's only all you want to
say I'm like yep only kindness matters
in the end they're like you know enough
it's enough it's a really great line
yeah I was like it's enough so I have to
talk to you about this because bonus
songs on the 25th inspired by like this
you only got these song There are songs
that you had recorded like in your life
or not recorded but like just played
yeah and there were fans that actually
recorded because you didn't remember
them yeah and you actually found a fan
you go to is his name Allan yeah this is
the most incredible story tell everybody
so I've always been prolific but I've
never written anything down and so I
lose songs all the time and so it was
the dawn of the internet so I'd get on
there on some list serve I'd be like
does anybody have a song called Jessica
that I sang once at a cafe in Toronto
and this guy would always write back and
go yeah I have that bootleg and yes I
have that one and yes I have that one I
was like do you want a job so I ended up
hiring him he's worked for me since like
94 or something like that
incredible so juel is is definitely a
Lyricist and a poet um and so in honor
of the 25th anniversary of her album
Spirit we want wanted to go back through
some of her lyrics so here's um the
first is from hands beautiful uh which
is on Spirit my hands are small I know
but they're not yours they are my own uh
but they're not yours they are my own
and I am never broken it's so simple
like even your bridg you said about the
kindness like it's so simple but that's
powerful a yeah what made you like write
that and stick with that you know I
wrote a lot of those lyrics When I was
homeless and I was shoplifting a lot and
I was trying to teach myself not to shop
shoplift um and people weren't very nice
to me at that time in my life I may
because shoplifting or yeah I mean it
wasn't a great it wasn't a great life
plan for sure but literally that lyric
was like these are mine nobody's making
me steal I'm choosing to do this even
though I'm homeless even though I have
no money even though I have no food this
is still my choice and I can do better
and I'm not broken but it really came
from this feeling of ownership I thought
I was yeah exactly yeah I love that I
didn't mean to make the joke but I had
to go there um okay so wait what more
this is from intuition and this is a
Joel's fifth album um so follow your
heart your intuition it will lead you in
the right direction let go of your mind
your intuition is easy to find just
follow your heart baby I feel like the
courses are never the poetic part
actually now that I'm looking at them um
for me that song was I wanted to write a
pop album yeah and it's very very hard
to write a pop hit without talking about
love and I counted how many times it's
been done and it's very very few and
challenged myself to write unless you're
hating on
it yeah um I guess that's yeah same yeah
cuz that's my catalog good catalog it's
working yeah so you got a got a thing
yeah so for me it was like how do I
write a song that's not about love
that's about like following your
instincts um so that was why I wrote it
I love that so the 25th anniversary
edition of juwels multiplatinum
sophomore album spirit is out November
17th and go online to learn more about
her second annual not alone Challenge
and how you can participate and also how
you can just get some information if you
need
[Music]
[Applause]
some thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home